[Applaudissements]
les slogans fusent la colère est
prégnante
hier selon le ministère de l'intérieur
près de 114 mille manifestants ont
dénoncé l'extension du passani terre en
france comme ici à paris
parmi les organisateurs du rassemblement
nicolas dupont aignan et florian
philippot ne mâchent pas leurs mots face
à la décision des manuels macro mais
unies on ait rassembler les forces ceux
qui sont quand même de tous horizons de
tous horizons et ça c'est formidable
aussi et je crois que les gens disent
stop voit la liberté
stop à cette discrimination stop à cet
apartheid stop à cette tyrannie macro
nist il faut arrêter le délire
communiste
c'est le début d'un engrenage vers une
dictature c'est un coup d'état
sanitaires c'est l'instrumentalisation
de la peur de la maladie
pour asseoir un pouvoir de plus en plus
illégitime preuve de la mobilisation
dans les pyrénées orientales département
récemment touchée par une forte reprise
épidémique et par de nouvelles mesures
de restriction
la mobilisation est forte au moins 1500
personnes ont sillonné perpignan pour
dire non au pass annie terre de son côté
le premier ministre jean castex
en visite dans les pyrénées atlantiques
a réaffirmé la volonté gouvernementale
ce variant delta il est là il ne faut
pas se cacher la vérité il progresse
il est très contagieux il est plus
contagieux que les variants précédent
nous devons nous aussi nous adapter
faire face en faisant en sorte que en
face peser le moins possible de
contraintes sur l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et pour ça je le répète et
je le répèterai elle a simplement il n'y
a qu'une solution en tout cas une
solution prioritaire c'est la
vaccination une stratégie qui convainc
une majorité de français selon deux
raisons sondage publié en début de
semaine
mais pour les pourfendeurs du passani
terre la parole gouvernementale ne passe
plus
de ce pas sanitaire mais j'en passe
crédit molle fait du mone que du mal je
veux pouvoir circuler marché aller faire
mes courses
vivre c'est une loi qui est totalement
abusive
c'est une loi qui divisent les français
c'est une loi qui est absolument
insupportable qui est disproportionné
par rapport à la situation
on va rappeler bien évidemment qu'en
face c'est pas rigolo c'est jésus corona
virus les vaccins sont pas au point donc
vacciner au pas vaccinés ça change pas
grand chose
des rassemblements qui se sont
globalement déroulées dans le calme même
si quelques échauffourées avec les
forces de l'ordre ont eu lieu à dijon ou
encore à lyon de nouvelles mobilisations
contre l'extension du passani terre
pourraient être organisées la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]